we come on the air with breaking news
we've been tracking this all afternoon
and we've just learned the metro
detective who was tragically killed in a
traffic incident this morning 45 year
old justin terry thank you for joining
us at 4 on this friday i'm kirsten joyce
and i'm brian loftis we are told
detective terry was on duty in his
unmarked metro police vehicle when the
incident occurred about seven o'clock
this morning nevada state police telling
us a tractor trailer carrying equipment
was driving through the construction
zone on the 95 under the 215 overpass
when it hit a metal beam overhead
causing it to fall onto the detective's
car
those beams are in place to make sure
that vehicles at a certain height don't
go underneath those you know the bridge
so that is all being investigated and
looked into currently
we're told the tractor-trailer involved
was not associated with ndot or the
construction project and that the driver
has been cooperating with the active
investigation impairment is not
suspected